bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal
préparé par la rédaction de tv 78 nous
sommes le jeudi 11 février voici les
titres de cette édition
l'hôpital de rambouillet la police
nationale s'associe une convention a été
signée ce matin pour améliorer l'accueil
et la prise de plainte des victimes de
violences conjugales initiative au
moment où le phénomène connaît une
hausse dans les signalements la visite
ce matin de geneviève darrieussecq dans
les yvelines la ministre déléguée aux
armées s'est rendu au lycée militaire de
saint cyr l'école sur place
l'inauguration d'un nouveau bâtiment
dans le cadre d'un vaste plan de
réhabilitation de l'établissement et le
dossier du bois de l'étang suscitent les
oppositions à la verrière la majorité
municipale prévoit une rénovation du
quartier avec démolition partielle une
proposition différente de celle portée
par le maire nicolas dainville lors de
la dernière campagne des élections
municipales il sera notre invité un
sujet à l'origine de tensions hier lors
du conseil municipal
focus également à la fin de ce journal
sur le théâtre
eurydice de plaisir un esat qui
accompagne les personnes en situation de
handicap dans leur projet professionnel
et ce grâce à la culture
en 2020 90 femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint ou ex conjoint selon le
ministère de la justice les signalement
pour violences conjugales ont été
également en hausse de 16% pour
améliorer l'accueil et la prise de
plainte des victimes le centre
hospitalier de rambouillet et la
direction départementale de la sécurité
publique des yvelines ont signé une
convention ce matin les précisions de
mélanie poker accompagner les victimes a
signalé des violences conjugales et
porté plainte avec cette signature
l'hôpital de rambouillet la police
nationale des yvelines renforcent leurs
liens
l'occasion pour nous de formaliser ce
passage de relais ce passage de entre
équipes et qui permet aussi de donner
confiance à l'équipe à la victime de
pouvoir la soutenir lorsqu'elle à cette
démarche difficile de devoir porter
plainte
à un moment donné contre contrat
conjoint le cadre
de l'hôpital sera plus sécurisant pour
ces personnes le fait qu'on vienne
directement qu'on soit présentée par
le personne avec laquelle elles ont déjà
un contact
privilégiez voilà c'est quelque chose de
très positif sur le temps psychologique
pour les victimes
50 à 70 % des patients identifiés comme
victimes de violences par les urgences
de rambouillet ne porte pas plainte
on pourra prendre nous mêmes de contact
avec la police pour donner le lieu
le lieu et l'heure de rendez-vous à la
dame ou la paix là où là la personne
victime de violence ça donne un attrait
un peu plus accueillant et chaleureux de
sur la démarche à faire elle les élèves
infirmiers et internes reçoivent depuis
le début de l'année une formation autour
de cette question
3000 cas de violence conjugale ont été
recensés dans les yvelines en 2020 après
plusieurs mois de travaux le lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école a
inauguré un nouveau bâtiment
d'hébergement geneviève darrieussecq
ministre délégué auprès de la ministre
désormais était présente ce jeudi matin
pour l'événement ces travaux ont eu lieu
dans le cadre du plan et lycées du
ministère astrid berges hérité sur place
un bâtiment flambant neuf encore vides
mais qui accueillera bientôt les élèves
de classes préparatoires du lycée
militaire de saint cyr l'école c'est
pour l'inaugurer que la ministre
déléguée auprès de la ministre des
armées geneviève darrieussecq a fait le
déplacement ce jeudi en soulignant ce
projet de bâtiment pol lapeyre tout
simplement
le démarrage de grands chamboulements
ici à saint cyr l'école chamboulement
positif bien sûr avec une amélioration
des conditions d'accueil des lycéens et
des étudiants
et ce premier bâtiment année le
témoignage puisqu'il va abriter
c'est un bâtiment d'hébergement pour les
étudiants en classes préparatoires
d'autres changements sont prévus dans
l'établissement un autre bâtiment va
être rénové d'ici 2022
il accueillera alors l'internât et celui
inauguré aujourd'hui deviendra un
bâtiment d'enseignement
ces travaux ont lieu dans le cadre du
plan l'iss et mis en place par la
ministre
j'ai mis en oeuvre un plan lycée avec un
plan d'investissements ambitieux dans
les établissements parce qu'il y avait
des certains établissements avec des
structures très vieillissante et qui
n'était plus aux normes du 21e siècle et
donc ce plan lycée a été décidée fin
les premiers plans ont été élaborés en
et là nous avons déjà la réalisation ici
à saint cyr l'école
le but que les élèves soit accueilli
dans de meilleures conditions
à la fin de cette visite rey la ministre
a tenu un comité directeur du plan lycée
pour suivre l'évolution des
investissements dans les établissements
concernés
ce mercredi c'est jean castex qui était
dans les yvelines nous en parlions hier
le premier ministre est venu à mantes la
ville avec la ministre de la transition
écologique
barbara pompili et la secrétaire d'état
emmanuelle wargon visite dans le cadre
de la loi climat et résilience voter le
matin même au conseil des ministres
l'objectif diviser par deux le rythme
d'artifice il artificialisation des sols
sur les dix prochaines années
le tout grâce à des réhabilitations de
friches et de foncier a dégradé pour ce
faire 300 millions d'euros du plan de
relance du gouvernement ils seront
dédiés d'ailleurs le premier ministre
vous l'avez vue sur ces images a visité
à mantes-la-ville la fusée qui va faire
l'objet d'une réhabilitation trois blocs
une université un jardin couvert et un
équipement culturel verront le jour sur
place et depuis quelques jours le
dossier de la rénovation du quartier du
bois de l'étang est au coeur des
tensions à la verrière
le projet de la nouvelle majorité
municipale prévoit une rénovation avec
une démolition partielle une proposition
différente de l'engagement de la liste
de nicolas dainville lors de la dernière
campagne des élections municipales
l'ancien maire communiste nelly duthu
aujourd'hui dans l'opposition et le
collectif des locataires du bois de
l'étang s'insurge face à cette décision
les explications de nicolas landry c'est
un dossier de longue date à la verrière
le projet de rénovation du quartier du
bois de l'étang
après s'être engagé durant la campagne
des municipales sur un projet sans
démolition
le maire nicolas dainville a choisi de
suivre une autre option celle de l'
agence nationale de rénovation urbaine
avec une démolition partielle les
financements pourraient atteindre plus
de 60 millions d'euros
d'après les premières estimations on
part sur une inscription dans l'anru
pour avoir le maximum de financement
possibles l'anru passe par quelques
démolition 20 millions d'euros pour
réhabiliter les intérieurs des
appartements les sols les plomberie les
sanitaires les halls les ascenseurs 20
millions d'euros pour les voiries les
espaces verts les aires de jeu 20
millions d'euros pour les équipements
une école une maison de quartier 2
millions d'euros pour sécuriser les
espaces et mieux les délimiter engagé
pendant la campagne sur un projet de
rénovation avec démolition
le conseiller municipal d'opposition
jean yves blé reste sur sa position pour
nous annonce de 160 logements détruits
nous nous étions plutôt sur quelque
chose sur une vous avez plusieurs
versions de proposer et nous étions sur
la deuxième version autour de 180
logements de son côté nelly du tube
ancien maire de la verrière aujourd'hui
conseillère municipale d'opposition est
toujours en faveur d'un projet de
rénovation sans démolition
elle a interpellé le maire sur le sujet
lors de la séance
que l'on soit pour ou contre les
démolitions sont tirés c'est pas le
sujet le sujet c
comment comment on fait autre chose que
ce qu'on avait dit sans prévenir
personne
on peut pas traiter les gens ont peut
pas traiter des habitants cette façon si
les habitants sont largement
majoritaires par des démolitions
d'apathie
mais encore faut-il déconcerté pour le
savoir
du côté de certaines associations
l'inquiétude grandit c'est le cas du
collectif des locataires du bois de
l'étang créé en 2014 qui m'a surpris
c'est que ben on n'a aucune visibilité
sur cette charte de relogement ni sur
les démolitions qui ont été privés
apparemment c'est david et son équipe
seul mais a fait ce qu'on veut c'est que
ce soit un projet qui soit il sépare les
habitants avec les habitants pour les
habitants tous les habitants doivent
être consultés pour donner leur avis
s'il ya des démolitions il y aura des
démissions s'il ya pas des
fonctionnaires pas d'évolution mais il
faut qu'on aille tous ensemble sur ce
projet qu'on laisse avec la municipalité
précédente
le maire annonce vouloir faire une
concertation avec les habitants sur la
base de son projet il prévoit la
démolition entre 214 et 264 logements
est avec nous justement par
visioconférence nicolas dainville
bonsoir bonsoir maire de la commune de
la verrière pour continuer à parler de
ce sujet du bois de l'étang qui
représente environ 2300 des 6500
habitants à la verrière on viens de
l'entendre dans le sujet nicolas d'un
deal entre 212 et 264 logements du
quartier pourraient être concernés par
une démolition est ce qu on sait quels
bâtiments sont concernés
alors déjà pour répondre à vos questions
tout l'enjeu c'est de réhabiliter les
appartements et les extérieurs mais pour
réhabiliter faut trouver de l'argent
soit pour trouver l'argent on bétonne
tout autour du quartier
c'était le projet de l'ancienne
municipalité qui avait missionné un
archipel qui s'appelait monsieur castro
qui voulait combler les vides et donc
vendre vendre massivement le foncier à
des promoteurs privés pour construire
500 à 600 nouveaux logements tout autour
du quartier pour trouver l'argent et
financer les réhabilitations ça ce
projet là dès qu'on l'a vu avec mon
équipe on l'a catégoriquement refusé
parce que ça aurait été invivable pour
les habitants du quartier donc ces
séquences
j'aide allant sur le sujet aujourd'hui
toi on passe par l'anru et donc c'est
l'anru que l'on choisit qui permet
d'avoir des financements conséquents
tels que jamais on pourrait en avoir à
la verrière sans l'anru et donc qui
passe effectivement par des démolitions
alors les démolitions de bâtiments
il y a effectivement des bâtiments qui
ne peuvent pas être démolies pour tout
un tas de raisons techniques
d'autres qui ont un intérêt
effectivement d'un point de vue urbain
pour que le quartier soit plus
accessible soit plus ouvert pour
composer une meilleure offre commerciale
et donc tout cela sera bien évidemment
abordé avec les habitants aujourd'hui il
est question de la charte de relogement
et denard l'émission pleinement de la
commune dans la rue on va en parler dans
un instant et ses financements rues sont
estimées à environ 60 millions d'euros
c'est justement c'est pour ces raisons
que vous avez évoqué que il ya là ce
changement d'avis de votre part puisque
on rappelle lors de la campagne que vous
étiez vous plutôt favorable à une
rénovation du quartier du bois de
l'étang mais sans démolition il coûtait
c'est vrai que quand on n'est pas amer
on n'a pas accès à toutes les
informations
depuis que je suis devenu maire j'ai eu
accès à ce à ce projet de l'ancienne
municipalité qui consistait à bétonner
pour trouver des financements et
réhabilité sur démolition c'est clair
que ça m'a fait froid dans le dos quand
je suis devenu maire j'ai eu aussi accès
aux services et aux partenaires qui ont
tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur le manque
d'attractivité du quartier et j'ai lu
accès aussi à tous à tout un ensemble
d'habitants qui sont venus me voir
qu'ils avaient du mal ou qui avaient
parfois peur de s'exprimer publiquement
dans les réunions publiques mais qui
m'ont dit qu'ils voulaient un changement
profond et donc tout cela m'a conduit
effectivement a évolué sur le sujet avec
un élément en plus vielles cette charte
de relogement qui au début pendant la
campagne n'existait pas et est en
travail pendant de longues années au
niveau de l'agglomération mais il n'y
avait pas d'accord
politique sur cette charte c'est chose
faite puisque on va pouvoir l'adopter au
niveau de l'agglomération et donc c'est
sécurisé tous les partenaires des
personnes qui seront contraintes d'être
logés avec des conditions très
avantageuses
oui vous apporte une garantie c'est ce
que j'avais les vous demandez les
personnes relogées ont cette garantie
enfin les personnes qui sont concernées
par par ces démolitions qui habite
actuellement cesser ces bâtiments vont
être garantie d'avoir une solution de
relogement
mieux grâce à cette charte duke ça c'est
que le critère de relogement le premier
critère de relogement c'est le choix des
familles il y aura des possibilités par
exemple pour l'aider cohabitent les
décohabitation pour les enfants pour les
parents directs le qui habitent dans le
logement y aura une prise en charge de
l'intégralité des frais de déménagement
et de transfert il y aura également une
prise en compte au cas par cas
un accompagnement individualisé
personnalisé des souhaits des ménages
pour soi rester dans le quartier s'ils
le souhaitent soit allé dans une ville
de l'agglomération
ils deviendront prioritaire dans leur
logement donc ils seront relogés en
priorité avec la mobilisation de tous
les contingents contingent de la
préfecture contingent des villes
contingent des onze bahia donc c'est des
conditions avantageuses extrêmement
favorable pour traiter dignement le
relogement des personnes qui seraient
concernées pour vraiment qu'elle puisse
évoluer au mieux voilà du mieux possible
voilà contiennent le plus en compte
leurs souhaits et on a vu aussi que
c'est un dossier forcément qui suscite
aussi des oppositions est ce que vous
comprenez nicolas dainville que certains
électeurs qui peut être avaient voté
pour vous en raison de votre position
sur le bois de l'étang
à l'époque tu sais être aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière se sentir tromper
est ce que ça vous pouvez le vous
l'entendez écoutez vous savez dans la
vie il faut aussi s'adapter à une
réalité
moi ma prise de position est elle se
fondait sur les éléments dont j'avais en
ma possession
quand je suis devenu maire j'ai vu une
réalité différente
j'ai vu des avis différents de ceux
uniquement sur lesquels on s'était
fondée j'ai vu aussi que la la la la
les choses évoluent cette charte
n'existait pas aujourd'hui elle existe
elle sécurise les parcours de relogement
et donc forcément ça change la donne ton
tout le pont de la villedieu le pont de
lavilledieu il va être intégralement
refaire réaménagé si on n'en profite pas
la verrière pour améliorer notre entrée
de ville dans le cadre de ce
réaménagement du pont de la ville yeux
la verrière passera à côté de tous ces
investissements
ces investissements il est en
discussions aujourd'hui ils ont été
confirmés par le département
bref vous savez quand on est maire les
choses elle évolué et c'est vrai qu'a eu
toutes ces évolutions qui m'ont conduit
avec mon équipe a à s'adapter à
s'adapter à cette nouvelle réalité et
donc j'assume totalement à d'avoir
évolué sur ce sujet à travers mes
rencontres à travers mes contacts avec
les partenaires à travers ces éléments
que je viens d'évoquer que sont surtout
la charte de relogement qui n'existait
pas auparavant une toute dernière
question il nous reste moins de 30
secondes nicolas dainville
il ya aussi une concertation qui va être
lancée du coup à quoi va t elle avait
été le servir ce que le dossier du coup
est enclenché sur quoi va porter cette
concertation qui a été lancé alors ça
fait sept ans que la concertation à la
lieu sept ans on a fait rêver les gens
je reprends même les termes de jean yves
blais qui est dans le groupe minoritaire
qui dit que beaucoup de choses ont été
de mensonges ont été racontées
clairement madame tutu s'est inscrit
dans le protocole de préfiguration du
lpr ua le nouveau programme national de
rénovation le web
l'anru donc le mk nru
axe n'accepte les dossiers que quand il
ya des démolitions donc c'était je pense
une extrêmement particulier de s'engager
dans ce process et de ne pas en profiter
pleinement
donc la concertation elle commence elle
a déjà eu lieu il ya eu toute une
enquête séquence qui a été mené avec
près de 265 familles qui ont répondu à
l'en-tête à une enquête très détaillées
telles que jamais elle avait été fait
dans le quartier une petite île bon
finalement des locataires comment une
petite partie finalement des locataires
les 265 avec foyer pour 145 %
sellal a quasiment la moitié des
locataires avec également des faux
tracts qui ont été fait pour décourager
les locataires de répondre à l' enquête
donc compte tenu de la crise sanitaire
et de ces événements le fait d'avoir
quasiment la moitié des locataires
c'est extrêmement bénéfique dans les
réunions publiques je vous rappelle il
n'y a pas autant de personnes qu'on peut
interroger donc c'est bien plus que le
nombre de personnes qu'on peut
interroger dans une réunion publique
quelques montres l'enquète elle montre
qu'il y a près de 60 % des locataires
qui envisagent de changer de logement
dans les années qui viennent
et parmi les 60 % qui envisagent de
changer de logement très 81% veulent
partir du quartier
donc c'est une réalité aussi qu'il faut
prendre en considération ces chiffres là
on les avait pas il ya quelques mois on
les a aujourd'hui donc je ne peux pas
faire comme si ça n'existait pas il faut
bien évidemment les prendre en compte
les prendre en considération et trouver
des réponses adaptées pour apporter
durablement des réponses concrètes pour
améliorer la vie du quartier
merci nicolas dainville pour toutes ces
précisions
l'actualité continue à être marqué
également par les propos de didier
lemaire le professeur de philosophie au
lycée de la plaine de neauphle attrape
il dit vivre pour rappel sous protection
policière menacé suite à sa prise de
position après l'assassinât de samuel
patty est nouvelle et nouvel élément le
préfet des yvelines jean jacques brot a
pris la parole dans un communiqué de
presse publié mercredi il revient sur
des propos qu'il a tenus dans un article
de nos confrères du monde dont ils
estiment qu'ils ont fait l'objet
d'interprétations pour certaines
malveillantes et qui tendrait à dire
qu'il sous-estimerait la situation de
l'islamisme attrape voici ses propos il
me paraissait contre productif de tenir
des propos définitive laissant à penser
que la bataille contre le séparatisme
était perdu dans ce territoire il me
paraissait également contre-productif et
de sembler stigmatiser les trente deux
mille habitants de cette ville fin de
citation par ailleurs on a appris dans
l'après-midi après cette prise de parole
du préfet que didier lemaire allait
quitter l'éducation nationale une
information sur laquelle nous
reviendrons et demain vendredi dans
notre édition du 7 8 week end c'est une
première dans les yvelines une formation
pour le personnel de la petite enfance a
été mise en place par la ville de
versailles et l'hôpital mignot est le
but aider ses agents à repérer les
troubles dus au neuro développement chez
les enfants aient les détails dans ce
sujet d'eléonore sinoquet de justin
brasier
une naissance sur 100 peut présenter des
troubles du neuro développement ou du
spectre autistique pour les repérer le
plus rapidement possible la ville et le
centre hospitalier de versailles
viennent de créer une formation spéciale
pour le personnel de la petite enfance
de la commune j'en étais convaincu que
y'avait que qui pouvaient former les
professionnels à la petite enfance tout
d'abord de la ville de versailles qui
vivent au quotidien avec ces petits
bouts qui déjà constatait des
problématiques et qui était un peu un
peu perdus vous ne savez pas trop
comment s'adapter comment faire et et
puis comment arriver à guider les
parents le plus vite et le mieux
possible vers vers les gens compétents
objectif donc donner les clés pour mieux
identifier pour ensuite mieux
accompagnés environ 200 personnes vont
être formés sur 14 demi journée elle
travaille dans les crèches de la ville
ou encore au relais d'assistants
maternels la formation elle est conçue
pour être très pratique les
professionnels observent le comportement
spontané des enfants dans les différents
temps de la crèche par exemple à
l'entrée dans la salle de motricité au
moment du repas du change etc mais aussi
qu'ils puissent est actif dans
l'observation en mettant en place des
petits temps de jeu que le truc du nord
au développement ont leurs repères
lorsque certaines compétences sont mises
en défaut par rapport au calendrier
habituel d'une re développement de
l'enfant la municipalité et le centre
hospitalier de versailles souhaite
également mettre en place une prise en
charge des enfants et des parents
une première qui pourrait être étendu
dans d'autres villes du département
on referme ce journal à plaisir le
théâtre eurydice et un esat c'est-à-dire
un établissement et service d'aidé par
le travail
il accompagne les personnes en situation
de handicap dans leur projet
professionnel l'objectif l'inclusion par
la culture justin brasier est allé à
leur rencontre
un théâtre qui fonctionne grâce à des
personnes en situation de handicap
objectif du théâtre eurydice sauvegarde
l'inclusion par la culture cv lettre de
motivation tous sont passés par un
entretien d'embauché
il ya un vrai travail de qualité ont
fait pas de l'occupationnel en esat du
tout on est là pour faire un travail de
qualité entre avec des clients on a des
délais à respecter une qualité à
produire tous les clients qui
travaillent avec nous sont contents en
tout cas est satisfait de là quelqu'un
de travail au programme ateliers de
confection de costumes construction de
décors régie son et lumière ou encore
troupe de comédiens les astres groupe
des travailleurs en situation de
handicap dans le domaine du spectacle
vivant
ils sont accompagnés par des
professionnels quand ils arrivent en mon
â ce qu'on appelle un
un projet adapté personnalisés donc
vraiment c'est un projet professionnel
ils nous disent ce qu'ils ont envie de
faire et non pas être là pour les
accompagner
on n'est pas là pour leur dire si c'est
réalisable pas réalisable voilà c'est
eux c'est leur projet on va faire au
mieux pour les accompagner là dedans
donc si l'objectif c'est de travailler
en milieu ordinaire est d'aller le
savoir faire de la restauration ben
voilà on va c'est travail avec petit à
petit il est 9h rovny karibe à les ath
le jeune comédien et malvoyants due à
une déficience visuelle de naissance
il fait partie de l'atelier théâtre
depuis quatre ans en avril 2016
il a passé un casting sur cinq jours
pour intégrer la structure
ce matin on a commencé les exercices
physiques
voilà d'une heure et après on a enchaîné
chacun travaille son texte moi je
travaille sur le mien à la ont répété
avec mon partenaire le feu par exemple à
aucun prix je ne me promènerai dans une
forêt qui flambent
mais moi je sais pourquoi pour moi pour
les textes les pièces de théâtre il faut
soit agrandi son bolide à ranger pour
moi pour qu'elle ait lieu normalement
ron roenicke a travaillé au
conservatoire de versailles pendant
trois ans parallèle de son
accompagnement à les at il souhaiterait
poursuivre dans la voie du spectacle
vivant
son but être comédien pourtant pas
évident de trouver une place
bah faut qu'elle soit utilisée comme ça
il a été acteur de casting accepte aussi
les personnes en situation de handicap
aussi parce que c'est difficile de
trouver une personne qui a envie de
travailler avec des comédiens pour leurs
57 travailleurs en situation de handicap
travail au théâtre a dit ça il faut
choisir
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de votre fidélité demain vendredi place
aux 7,8 week-end une émission qui mêle
actualité et idées de sorties et loisirs
pour bien terminer la semaine dans les
yvelines est aux manettes bien sûr
eléonore sinoquet et célia gars de 100
go belle soirée à tous avec tv 78
[Musique]